oh hey it's Kat hey it's veronica from
the real rejects how are you guys doing
today what's going on guys what's up
we're going to do a trailer reaction
today to the rewrite Ryan couldn't be
with us yeah unfortunately he could not
be with us today you know we really
should let him out of the trunk it's
kind of hot outside it's only like 100
though oh yeah Hank it would be okay if
it was over a hundred then we would take
him out of the trunk but their air holes
he'll be fine yeah he deserves it cars
have their holes think three right right
incidence october eight in the award for
best original screenplay go it's like a
youtube video with a new creature was an
additive on Capri my room there is
something you have to hear me out you
thought of me for teaching your teaching
practice by desperate ranges it I'll
take I don't believe that anything worth
knowing can be taught I intend to do as
little as possible while carrying on
with this charade he's a sexy hair
lotion welcome you to the screenwriting
class brother doesn't look like he's
aged in like the past language from
different hair sexy older actually I
myself will have to looks it's wonderful
going back to school with your work hey
don't you men know I just have a
question I would expect no less if you
don't believe writing can be taught this
is it gonna be doing in the class so the
truth is that I'm going to be writing a
movie about a teacher it's going to be
in it I'm not ability to discuss that
matters demon you arrived on campus he
came in Italy and insulted members
faculties don't like Jane Austen haha
just a little it x 3 mother power
this is just another more safe jane
austen's a hundred percent announced how
she so that means to a beauty never
jitterbug see about when we try to get
married spiritual they can see all on
your movement yes here where's never my
son's my funny woman for the fire
honestly i found myself missing you it's
quite possible that if I stayed away my
eyes I just completely got over that box
now will let me know Oh beautiful yeah
they just want hoping and tell me if
Matt wants me to Africa man who is
naturally cushioning was only one
Gosling or rattles OH human Ryan should
see that together that would be so cute
I like the older cast you know the leads
are yeah I'm really today they're
classic actors am and it's funny to I
mean I love you grant I love him on
family guy who's like I'm so charming
even buttled it's like a movie my
parents would definitely enjoy watching
like there's probably no intense sex
scenes or awkward moments like that so I
think they would be able to get through
it together yeah that actually reminds
me one time I tried to watch 50 year old
virgin with my parents I guess they just
like printed it or something and I
stopped their kind of with them
awkwardly for like the first innocent I
just couldn't take it I was like okay
this is too weird I maybe I just can't
do it I was staying with an older lady
she was like 60 60 something really 16
she was a really kind sweet woman and
one day we wanted to go out to the
movies so I checked what was playing and
one of the only ones i was playing was
much anything oh yeah i took a 60
something-year-old woman to see machete
it's kind of badass how would you think
of it um think she liked it very much Oh
anyway so moving along if you are new to
the Channel please subscribe we would
really
she ate it and I think you would too I
think you'd appreciate us and Ryan's
pretty cool I guess we are going to be
taking over his channel though so just
you know keep that in mind hot chicks
great great for uh great for your
viewing pleasure hey I mean look at her
oh yeah her teen yeah all right I'm like
like big and bulky compared to you well
it no little it's it's camera angle C
look now I'm bigger yeah so you know
she's teaching me just teach me a thing
or two we don't really care we don't
care what you guys think really don't we
do we love you please subscribe please
subscribe so let me love you guys so
let's do shout out so did you have
anyone you wanted to shout out to I'd
like to give a shout-out very special
shout-out to Michelle Fernandez you seem
like a really cool chick okay I met you
on the real rejects channel and we
skyped you were cool then and now you're
hanging out on my channel it's really
close you're giving me your love and I
appreciate it here's some love back did
you want to see I just watched this
really cute youtube video who is this
guy in his grandma and it made me miss
my grandparents so i think i want to
give a shout out two grand mother and
grandma I love you guys you're so cute
and maybe one day I'll get to put you on
the internet for everyone to see to you
so oh that is so kind so hey guys love
you um one more Callie I forget the last
few numbers of your of your name but we
met uh from my show that I did I did a
acoustic set and she was there what's up
Cali here's your shoutout like Halle
great so I guess that's right internship
maybe we should check on him he's been
really quiet for a long time it was nice
hanging out with you guys but I think I
gotta go check and see if my boyfriend
still alive in our trunk all right can I